SPEAKER: I'd like to welcome
Marc Theermann to the stage
to talk about the next level
of in-game advertising.
This is important for
all of you if you're
looking to make money.
And I think it probably is.
So let's welcome Marc.
[APPLAUSE]
MARC THEERMANN: My name is Marc.
I'm part of the Publisher
Business Solutions team
here at Google.
Publisher Business Solutions is
the organization within Google
that's responsible to help
our publishers make money
from advertisements.
You already heard from John
about AdMob, our publisher
business platform for
application developers.
I want to talk a little bit
more general about application
advertising, the
ecosystem at large,
and what advertising
means at Google.
The great news is that
advertising dollars
are flowing into the ecosystem
at a rate never seen before.
Just over the last 18
months, the ecosystem
has grown tremendously,
and in-game advertising
is now a multibillion
dollar industry.
So that's good news.
And there's a couple
of different ways
of how you could get your
hands on these dollars.
This slide shows where
this demand is currently
coming from, and you'll notice
that the biggest chunk still
comes from media and
entertainment advertisers.
And that's not a surprise.
A lot of that is other
games advertising in games,
and you guys have seen this.
But what I find really
exciting about this
is that retail advertising is
the fastest growing segment
for us.
This is a whole
new advertiser that
is coming to the table
with new dollars.
So this is mobile
commerce retailers
that are bringing advertising
and trying to bring users back
to the e-commerce experiences.
So this is something that
we're going to monitor closely,
and I think you'll notice a
positive ECPM increase because
of these advertisers coming in.
There's a couple
of different ways
of how you could reach
these advertisers.
Let's look at those three.
The first one is you could
entrust your impressions
into an ad network.
That ad network would
go out to advertisers
and represent your
inventory for you.
Secondly, you can
talk to advertisers
directly by hiring a
direct sales force.
Or, the newest way, you
could expose your impressions
into an RTB exchange and
let multiple advertisers
bid on your impressions.
So let's take a look at each of
those three in more specifics.
Ad networks are often the
first line of defense,
and are the oldest
part of the ecosystem,
and have been around pretty
much since the beginning
of the internet.
Google actually runs one of the
larger ad networks on the web,
it's called the Google
Display Network or GDN.
And it can be accessed through
all of our publisher solutions
platforms.
So the great way-- Network
make great partners
because they usually
don't cost money,
and they work on
a by-share basis.
So other than the
integration cost
that you have of
integrating a new network,
you don't have to
hire a sales force,
so most of the money that
you get from an ad network
is pure profit.
And that's what makes
them so popular.
Interestingly enough,
despite the fact
that they have been around
the longest in the ecosystem,
I see a lot of innovation
on that part of the house.
So there's probably half
a dozen of really exciting
start-up companies
out there right
now that are innovating
on the demand side.
So that's great news.
Because networks
take a revenue share,
certain publishers decide to
hire their own sales force
and approach
advertisers directly.
Direct advertising sort
of refers to any ad
that you solicited
directly, or you
talk to an advertiser
directly, hence the name.
So let's assume
that you have gotten
great success with your game.
You are now a company of,
let's say, 30 people or so.
And because of your
game's success,
a couple of advertisers
have started
to reach out to you directly.
And maybe you've even taken
in some sponsorship dollars
and hard-coded a sponsorship
ad into one of your games.
If that is where
you are today, it
might be time to hire
your first salesperson.
Why would you go to the expense
of hiring that salesperson?
Well, there is no
hard and fast rules,
but direct
advertisements probably
monetize at a rate of 10%
to 30% higher than those ads
that you would get
from a third party.
So you hire your
first salesperson,
let's call him Mike.
And Mike goes out there, and
after a few short months,
he brings back his first
advertisement from, let's say,
Procter & Gamble, one of the
largest advertisers in mobile.
Procter & Gamble would like
to reach your audience,
but they don't want
to reach everybody.
They want to pay premium to
reach only your female audience
in San Francisco, every
Thursday, from 3:00 to 7:00,
for a period of seven
months, and at the time,
no other ads are allowed
to be in your game.
So if that sounds
daunting, then you
know where an ad
server comes in.
Pub-side ad servers help you
execute advertisements, traffic
your campaigns, and
allocate impression
into all the different ad
sources that are out there.
If you have multiple
advertisements running--
and some of our publishers
have hundreds or thousands
ads that want to be
delivered at any given time--
the ad server takes on
one more particular role
which is called pacing,
meaning it allocates
specific impression
to the ads that
need to be delivered
at any given time.
Finally, for games
in particular,
ad servers could serve
one other important role,
and that's that of house ads.
House ads are any
notifications that you
want to send to your audience.
It might be to advertise
a new game that you have.
It might be to advertise a
new level, a new feature.
It might even be to serve
in-application goods.
The Google ad
server, by the way,
is called DoubleClick for
Publishers, or DFP for short.
In its newest iteration, it
was built with mobile in mind.
And many of the largest
publishers in the world
rely on it because
of its scalability
and because of its reliability.
So at this point it might
be important to note
that for most of our publishers
this is not a replacement.
So the world's largest
publishers usually do both.
They have a direct
ad sales force,
and they also talk to networks.
So let's look at the latest
way to monetize impressions,
something that has
really only been around
for a few short years, and
it's called real-time bidding.
When mobile traffic
started to explode,
publishers noticed
that a single ad
network and their
direct sales force
was not enough to fill
all their impressions.
So what they often did was
to talk to multiple networks
in a sequence of events
often called a daisy chain.
Some publishers attempted to
run these daisy chains in-house.
Most publishers would
deploy technology middleware
called yield management.
Yield management has some
significant advantages,
but it also has a
couple of disadvantages.
On the one hand,
calling networks
in a sequence of
events costs time.
And time means
discrepancy, and that
means potential loss of revenue.
But secondly, and
probably more importantly,
calling ad networks in
a sequence of events
means that you might not be
choosing the most ideal ad.
Think of it like this.
You go to a speed dating event,
and the speed dating event
has a couple of special rules.
Rule Number 1, you need
to pick the first girl
that you're attracted to.
Rule Number 2, you have
to pick a contestant
at the end of the game.
And Rule Number 3 is
you're not allowed
to see any of the girls that
come after you made a pick.
So you go to the event.
You don't like Girl Number 2.
Girl Number 1, Girl Number
2, but Girl Number 3
is very smart and
cute, so you pick her.
Unfortunately, Megan Fox
was in Seat Number 4,
and you didn't get to
meet her, and by the way,
she really likes gamers.
So that's yield management.
It means you make a
decent pick, but you
don't make the perfect pick.
And that's where RTB comes in.
RTB sort of replaces
a sequence of events
with a simultaneous call.
A few years ago,
technology providers
started to experiment with
RTB by building exchanges
that pretty much work like
the New York Stock Exchange.
You expose your impressions
into an auction.
Multiple parties
raise their hand
with a specific price
and advertiser in mind.
And the highest bidder
wins the auction.
So the sequence of
calls is replaced
with a simultaneous
call, which is
much more efficient
and scalable.
So brace for impact,
here comes the sales part
of my presentation.
Google has a
technology suite that
allows you to access all
these demand sources.
With our publisher
platforms, you
can access our own ad networks
as well as other networks.
You can run a
direct sales force.
And, of course, you
can expose impressions
into our RTB platform, which
has about 400 bidders connected,
bidding on behalf of
millions of advertisers.
If you were to do
that, let's talk
about integrations for a second.
All of our solutions are now
available in a single SDK,
which includes AdMob,
it includes DFP,
it includes the DoubleClick
Ad Exchange and now Analytics.
This SDK is also baked into
the core Android services,
into the core Android
Play services.
So for your Android
traffic, you don't
need to update the SDK
anymore and relaunch
your app into the app store.
It now happens for most of
the updates automatically.
We strive very hard to
make updates to our SDKs
and continuously improve it.
The latest SDK, which
includes these auto-update
functionalities, was
launched in January.
So if any of you are
using an SDK from us that
is older than that, I'd highly
recommend that you update.
You'll likely make more
money, and it should likely
be much easier to
manage in the future.
So we've done the
hard work for you.
We've given you the technology
and pipelines to connect you
into all these demand sources.
But there's a couple
of things that you
can do to optimize the
monetization of your game.
So let's look at those.
The first one is
building audiences.
Yes, mobile advertising
is still in its infancy.
But if desktop advertising
is any indication,
the future winners will be
those publishers and games that
foster a deep relationship
with their audiences,
and especially those that
foster a deep relationship
with their audience
across different screens.
More screens are coming.
But even if your game is just
available on a single screen
today, most likely you will
be on different devices
in the future.
So think about that
future and think
about how you can build a
long-lasting relationship
with your audience
across multiple screens.
One way to do that might
be a registration flow.
A registration flow is one
of the more privacy-safe ways
to build a long
term relationship
and engage your audience.
So I would highly recommend
that you think about doing that.
Clearly, you can build your own.
You could also use Gmail as a
universal login through Google+
integration.
The benefit there is
that lots of people
have Gmail accounts
already so it
makes signup a
little bit easier.
And we actually share audience
information back with you
so that you can use that
to target your audiences.
The next big driver is formats.
Choosing the right format
and the right placement
in your game is
absolutely critical.
You want to provide
advertisers a chance
to engage with your audience but
without bothering your users.
So while there's many
options to choose from,
I would recommend that you pick
one of the standard IAB units
because much of
the world's demand
is flowing into those formats.
Over the last couple
of months, we've
seen tremendous success
with interstitials units.
Interstitials are ads that
fill out the entire page,
but give users the
option to skip or opt out
of the interstitial.
When we analyze our data, we see
that advertisers and consumers
alike continue to be very
excited about interstitials.
So I would recommend
that you take a look
and see if interstitials are
the right thing for your game.
So that almost concludes what I
wanted to share with you today,
but I also wanted to
give you a quick look
into the future of
some of the things
that we are doing with
regards to new formats.
Our product and
engineering teams
are working pretty hard to
bring new formats to you.
This year alone,
we're going to be
launching a variety
of new formats.
Now here are three that
I particularly like.
Clearly, location-based
advertising
is a very big
promise for a device
that's always in your pocket.
So we are working
hard to figure out
how we could provide a
privacy-friendly environment
in which advertisers can
strive and really push
the ecosystem
forward with regards
to location-based advertising.
Location-based advertising
requires consumer opt-in,
so I would urge you to talk
with your product teams
and see if there
is features that
could be built into your
game that would be better
through location, so
that you can collect it.
Secondly, video seems
to be the next frontier
for mobile advertising.
We launched video formats
at the end of last year,
in a skippable
format that you've
known from YouTube which
is called TrueView.
It gives the
consumer the ability
to skip the video
if they don't find
the advertisement
relevant for them.
So a lot more video innovation
coming from us this year, so
keep your eye out there.
And then last but
not least, you've
probably noticed that we've
started to include apps
in the search experience
on Google Search.
So that's a very big
driver for us this year,
helping you guys so that
games can be easier discovered
through our search experiences.
So that almost concludes
my presentation for today.
I want to leave you
with a final thought.
I think it's important to note
that not all of our publishers
make equal amounts of money.
The spread is
actually fairly large,
which means that
we can provide you
with the technology
and the pipelines
into all the possible
demand sources.
But it really takes dedication,
and it takes a lot of tenacity,
and it takes attention
to detail to really make
the most out of your
monetization suite.
So we've created lots
of developer pages
online that might help you to
make some of those decisions.
But, of course, you
should never hesitate
to reach out to us directly,
and reach out to the Publisher
Business Solutions
organization within Google,
because we would love
to hear from you.
So thank you so much,
and I'll be around
if anybody has questions.
And I hope you have a great day.
[APPLAUSE]